hi i'm aisha curry and i'm stephan curry
and we're here with buzzfeed to take the
relationship test
you should know this birthday you know
my birthday yes i know your birthday
oh
march 14 1988. that's correct yours is
uh march 23rd 1989.
all right let's go your astrological
sign you are a pisces and you are an
aries that is correct thank you let's
keep going your mother's nickname for
who each other
do you know mine e.t god damn you're
right
i hate this
first impression of you
your first impression of me was i was
the cute boy at church
that is correct your first impression of
me was that i was cute
yes i have one other
and different add one other
disclaimer you were canadian there you
go
favorite date night activity a glass of
wine dot dot dot and i'm gonna say
you're gonna say get it
popping favorite physical feature my
shoulders
that that is it it's it's his back but i
guess shoulders counts it's more back
here though my feet yes
you ask the question you're such a
weirdo oh don't
mess where it's going you're such a
weirdo
oh favorite movie oh
i got yours sandlot no
what what
[Laughter]
come on
most used phrase let's jump right in
[Laughter]
uh yours is yes ma'am that's that's like
that all right biggest pepe
biting my nails
no it's when you leave popcorn
everywhere that is absolutely true yeah
your
biggest pet peeve of mine is when i
think negative thoughts about myself
see
that's true that's not a pet peeve what
was it
the dirt the dirtiness in the closet
it's not dirtiness there's clothes in
the closet that aren't hung up that's
corny that's nice
my side of the closet has been cleaner
than yours
but the fact that we're talking a very
small sample size is part of the okay
uh so there's no checks there
your favorite adult beverage is a
right now currently
a gin and tonic
no
champagne yeah glasses
it did change yours is a nice small pour
of your finest
scotch
i'll take my points
hidden talent you have to say yes
because this is uh this is the answer i
don't care what you this is that you can
sing
that is the answer but i don't think
that that's my hidden talent that is the
answer but i don't think that's my
hidden talent no i think my hidden
talent is that i think i'm psychic
but see you haven't necessarily proven
that too that's true many people you
like that
i'm getting that one your hidden talent
oh how fast you can fly through a bag of
sunflower seeds
i was gonna say uh juggling or the
rubik's cube all right fine shoe size
you are a twelve and a half that is
correct and you are a
uh
ten and a half in women's ten
i mean
that's close enough ten i went over two
so you can fit in my shoes
saudi is a tent
love language oh this is a good one
yours is quality tone
yes that's correct yours is physical
touch favorite way to relax
i'm gonna say yours is golf yes it is
okay you thought i was gonna say now i
did uh take take a bath that is correct
with epsom salts please and thank you
and it was wine also remember that
the first time you realized they were
interested in you so this is very
complicated question because
uh our
origin story is a relationship there's
different timelines according to
different
people in this thing so like our first
date was not to say our first date to
her
therefore i'm i'm very confused about
this answer because i'm going to say the
first time that you
i realized that you were interested in
me
was outside of ryburn dorm at davidson
college before you went to drive home
what how could that be the first time
it was interesting
not love you
interested i miss those loved foot do
you want to redo no you don't get the
point you don't get the point
the first time i realized you were
interested in me was when i accidentally
dodged your kiss in the studio because
you came at my face when i was speaking
mid-conversation i got curved and i i
didn't even get curved i didn't know
what was happening and i just didn't
think i was cool enough for you so i
couldn't believe it russia but i liked
you too
you get the point out now i love you
their favorite song to listen to when
they're down
please get this right please get this
straight please get this right you know
this you know this leon bridges
and it's called oh my gosh what the [ __ ]
what's it called it's i've i blanking on
it i just know it's him
and so we're single it's like a city
is it
what's it called blue masons
by leon bridges i don't think you're
gonna have to
i could i could find it might go to
apple your favorite song to listen wait
wait wait let me answer this first
because
all
i
so we're in wells hills and valleys
no
no i'm happy when i listen to that song
but no it makes you happy
no i usually have because that's canon
song lupe fiasco superstar
why
because i wouldn't
take these places that's a weirdo
you won you got 13. i won i got 12. i
beat you by one that's nothing i'll take
it we are true soul mates
i know you and i love you and i can't
wait to spend eternity with you and just
like that i'm the winner
but only by one point you got it done i
i i'm gonna go back to the booth and i'm
i'm calling a red flag on some of those
questions not red flag but the yellow
flag like a penalty on some of those
answers but maybe next ain't no red
flags here sorry ain't no red flag ain't
no red flags here watch about last night
now streaming on hbo max you can binge
watch all the episodes that's it
[Music]
you